we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here is a
voicemail that came in with a very
specific request for a long-form video
for us to do take a listen to this hey
David
uh I have a request for you if possible
could you please do a point-by-point
debunk of the bell curve on developer
has had a recent re insurgents there's a
lotta you know controversy around that
book of course and I think it'd be
really important to actually go by point
by point on an educational visual
analysis of why the bell curve is flawed
alright thanks man so for people who
don't know the bell curve is the book by
charles murray which has recently come
back to the sort of forefront of the
minds of many in what is loosely
referred to as the intellectual dark web
it is a book that makes a variety of
assertions including about race and IQ
and you know i'm not against doing like
a long-form video looking specifically
at the claims of charles murray in the
bell curve we did do a long-form piece
on race and IQ more generally and the
book the bell curve was a pretty
significant part of that if people were
really that interested in it it appeared
as though it would be substantive ly
different enough to make sense to put
time into it i'm totally up for doing a
long-form piece on charles Murray's the
bell curve specifically I just don't
know how much more we would get out of
it specifically then what we got from
the more general race and IQ video so
send me your thoughts about that we also
by the way I haven't talked about
long-form pieces for a little while
because we're right now in the throes of
production of the pseudoscience of
mini-series which is going to be a
twelve part miniseries debunking such
pseudo-sciences as psychic Uri is it
called psychic re or psychic ism or
psychic arts I don't know what to call
it
homeopathy astrology extrasensory
perception Detox's and cleanses we've
got this long list 12 different
pseudo-sciences which we're going to be
debunking in a mini series set to stuff
release in July so all other long-form
stuff has basically been on hold but on
our list a lot of people have been
asking for a long-form piece debunking
Jordan Peterson's nonsense that is one
that I think would do pretty well but I
questioned the usefulness of it because
as I've explained before with Jordan
Peterson if you already see him as a
charlatan
then our piece wouldn't really achieve
much and if you're an adherent of Jordan
Peterson you would just claim we are
miss attributing views to him right that
we're misquoting him or distorting what
he said so I actually don't know whether
a long-form piece on Jordan Peterson
would be that useful so let me know do
you want the long-form piece on Jordan
Peterson are you interested in a
long-form debunking of Charles Murray's
the bell curve and if you have other
ideas for long-form pieces by all means
let me know we've got a great bonus show
coming up for you today we will talk
about how birth rates have dropped the
most in the United States in counties
where home values have increased the
most that is an interesting correlation
we will also talk about FCC chairman
Ajit PI twisting the meaning of the open
Internet and we are going to talk about
something that I guess it's stressful to
me and it's called traffic in Boston I
really do not do well driving in traffic
I have been known to I don't really have
road rage where i rage at other drivers
I have general traffic rage I just can't
handle driving in traffic it's the
biggest waste of time and if you report
says that Boston has the worst traffic
in the country so all of those stories
and more are coming to you on today's
bonus show two ways to access the bonus
show sign up at join pakman.com there's
a 40% off coupon code vote soon 18 which
you can take advantage of anytime also
you can become a patron at the $5 or
higher level at patreon.com slash david
pakman show both options give you
instant access to the world-famous bonus
show and we will speak to you then in
mere minutes